Nitrogen triad died is a well-known compound that has been used by
chemical pranksters. Since I don't know when,
when I was a school, boy, I made some, and it went off with a nucleus.
[Inaudible].
When you make it, it comes out as a damp,
rather dark colored compound.
When you spread it out on the surface to dry it dries relatively
quickly and then becomes a so-called contact explosive.
If you touch it even very gently, it can go off with a live bang.
So what we did was to put it on a warm surface,
Neil had a hot plate with a metal sheet on top to protect it.
And it was put on the filter paper to dry,
took quite a long time to dry nearly half now,
but then he touched it off with a new tool that is
invented, which he called a professor on the stick.
Like most chemical reactions.
It needs some energy to set it off,
but this one needs very little energy, physical energy,
just rubbing two crystals together is enough to get it going.
So it's rather like something that is about to overbalance and you
just need to give it a little push.
And the result was pretty dramatic.
So the chemistry is really quite simple and I three dissociates
into nitrogen gas and to an ID and end to
has a very strong bond between the two nitrogen atoms.
So it releases a lot of energy very quickly.
And as it releases the energy, of course it accelerates the reaction.
And so it all goes off or nearly all goes off at once.
You also get a cloud of ID in vapor,
which is a sort of brownie purple color. In fact,
the unfortunate little professor disappears among the clouds and
comes out covered in ID though,
I managed to wash the ID in of the professor using sodium
sulfate, occasionally will go off spontaneously like my sample in my locker at
school. Well,
my experience was that like many people they've tried to make quite a large
amount. It was hidden in my locker. So the teacher shouldn't find it.
And then it dried out when I opened the door,
whatever I did was enough to set it off. So there was a big bang. Fortunately,
I was not in any way hurt, but it was quite a lesson to me.
Chlorine compounds,
nitrogen tri chloride is a liquid and is far worse.
The French chemist peered you long,
who discovered it lost an eye and two fingers,
or some people say three fingers when it exploded.
And when Humphrey Davey in London was trying to repeat the experiment.
He got some glass in his eye, then his assistant,
Michael Faraday tried it and injured his hand.
And one whose fingernails came off.
So nitrogen trifluoride is truly dreadful compound,
but the TRIA died because it's a solid has been used for
many, many years. And in fact,
we discovered in the archives here a really quite nice account
of a debate between two university teams,
one from Nottingham and one from Swanzey that took place in
1928. One of the students,
no Kuser wrote in the account. So it begins quite formerly.
There was an InterVarsity between university debate that year at
Nottingham, it was held in the lounge theater.
He then explains how the students were very badly behaved shooting
peas out of pea shooters from their mouths, at the audience in the front,
and then on the people debating on the stage.
But what the people on the stage didn't know was that the pranksters were
chemistry students and they had put nitrogen TRIA died,
which was damp all over the stage.
So one of the people from Swanzey got up and was walking up and down the stage,
trying to calm everything down.
And then it happens the nitrogen tri iodide liberally
spread earlier on the platform began to dry out and each step of the
SWAT ANSI man produced alarming crackles and bangs until
all those on the days,
that's the stage disappeared up to their knees in a valid
haze. At this point, the proceedings were called off.
So you see even a long time ago, students could be really badly behaved.
In fact, far more badly behaved than would be permitted. Nowadays.
That's a university,
obviously this is not the sort of reaction you should try at
home because this compound is terribly unstable.
It is being used by people because even microscopic
amounts make quite a loud bang and it's particularly dangerous.
If you make a large amount of this material,
even in the live where we were working, making this video,
we spilled some on the floor
and they were crackles for an hour or two afterwards.
Hi, you probably just heard the professor mentioned.
Sometimes you can suffer a premature detonation of your nitrogen.
Tried it. We did experience such a problem, and we also captured it on video.
If you'd like to see it, I'll include a link in the video description.
And while I have your attention,
can I also just thank everyone who supports periodic videos on Patrion,
helping us go the extra mile details about that can also be found down below the
video.